congratulations to the class of 2017
today is Mother's Day so I'm going to
ask all of the seniors to stand and
acknowledge your mothers your
grandmother's your aunts and other
guardians please stand and give them a
round of applause thank you please be
seated
action stone above the entrance to earl
hall are the words erected for the
students that religion and learning may
go hand in hand and character grow with
knowledge we remain committed to that
aspiration in a world far more complex
than any of us might ever have imagined
each of you talented seniors is
testimony to the hope that we keep
sacred it is with courage and faith that
we commend you and say come let us
reason together I would like to ask our
Dean's to stand and be acknowledged
Dean Valentini Provost Bell seen voice
seen on Dean Kingston came from
Dean Hartford thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone my name is Umrah
maltzman I am in general studies and the
Jewish Theological Seminary I'll be
reading an excerpt today from the book
of Deuteronomy from Moses final speech
to the Israelites and he says surely
this instruction which I oh joy upon you
this day is not to battling for you nor
is it beyond reach it is not in the
heavens that you should say who among us
can go up to the heavens and get it for
us and impart it to us that we might
observe it neither is it beyond the sea
that you should say who among us can
cross to the sea to the other side of
the sea and retrieve it for us and
imparted to us that we might observe it
no the instruction is very close to you
in your mouth and in your heart to
observe it behold I have put before you
life and death blessing and curse choose
life if you and your offspring would
live by loving God heating God's
commandment commands and holding fast to
God for thereby you shall have life and
shall long endure that God swore to your
ancestors Abraham Isaac and Jacob to
give to them thank you
[Applause]
good morning good morning happy brothers
happy Mother's Day mom my name is
Dominic velu I'm graduating from Barnard
class of 2017 and I will be reading a
passage that's helps my Christian
journey from Exodus and this is Moses
speaking to the Lord
experts for 2016 Moses said to the Lord
pardon your servant Lord I have never
been eloquent neither in the past nor
since you have spoken to your servant I
am slow of speech and tongue the Lord
said to him who gave human beings their
mouths who makes them deaf or mute who
gives them sight or makes them blind is
it not I the Lord now go I will help you
speak and will teach you what to say but
Moses said pardon your servant Lord
please send someone else then the Lord's
anger burned against Moses and he said
what about your brother Aaron the Levite
I know he can speak well he is already
on his way to meet you and he will be
glad to see you
you shall speak to him and put words in
his mouth
I will help both of you speak and we'll
teach you what to do in this passage God
is relentless even within his anger he
provides mercy and a brother to guide
Moses from the doubt and the fear that
stings him and while at Bernard over
these past four years her God has
provided me with a family that keeps me
on course with his mission and that
keeps me away from succumbing to my own
fear in doubt so I am forever blessed
for the people for the friends
for the deans for the family that
accompany in this process thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]
Oh
that
[Music]
when it's fresh
[Applause]
hello friends family and graduates and
my six family members and friends in the
audience I want you to join me in saying
vigor ji ka khalsa waheguruji ki fateh
my name is Harleen Kaur and I am
graduating from Barnard College I am
here reading for the Sikh faith I will
be reading a piece from the Guru Granth
Sahib our holy scripture and our
eleventh and last guru a piece that is
written by our fifth guru guru Arjun
baiji I chose this reading in
celebration of all of our successes here
at Columbia and to serve as a reminder
to myself that I would not be here if it
were not for Vaheguru the one creator
and force we believe connects all across
faiths and beliefs Maha Maha Shiva
Bhoomi repite - hey Mira Mata boom era
bandha / - Mira brothel - Mira la cárcel
beneath hi Baba kaha cardiology phonetic
ripple through the pagina to midi or
Telugu hell Miramar na food in Abuja
over in Ocoee
Zapatera kala a cardiology
you'll geez and the Sabbath Aveo by and
jibba jibba par non-digital a subacute
Akita did a hole and now he get to a
Sardar ji na my belly my heart so Copiah
Hara gonna go mera municipal ayah guru
Buddha a diva da na Nicosia tava
cartagia-- nama tell mehat occupy all
hardcore Nogami Ramon acetyl aya guru
Buddha a Jeeva dari non nikachita big
hard RG the translation reads you are my
father
you are my mother you are my family and
you are my brother you are my protector
everywhere so why should I feel any fear
or anxiety by your blessings I recognize
you
you are my shelter and you are my honor
without you there is no other the entire
universe is the arena of your play you
have created all beings and creatures
and as it pleases you you assign tasks
to one at all all things are your doing
and we can do nothing ourselves
meditating on your naam your name I have
found great peace singing the praises of
the one my mind is soothed and cooled
through the perfect guru congratulations
are pouring in Nanak is victorious on
the arduous battle field of life thank
[Applause]
assalamo allaikum good morning my name
is faizon Kothari I am a senior in
Columbia College and I'll be reading a
verse from the Quran our ability min
ash-shaytani r-rajim bismillahi r-rahman
r-rahim
yeah Yohann Nasu in a holic nikumans
occur in Vantaa module naka mobin Wakaba
ellen Vitara Phu in Accra Macomb in the
LA he at kharkom inna llaha le monde
Kabir the translation reads o mankind we
created you from a single pair of a male
and a female and made you into nations
and tribes that you may know one another
not that you may despise one another
verily the most honoured of you in the
sight of Allah is he who is the most
righteous of you and Allah has full
knowledge and is well-acquainted with
all things what I really like about this
verse is that it not only talks about
differences as a strength but it makes
them cosmically cosmically derived with
divine intent and divine wisdom we're
all leaving a heterogeneous university
to enter into a more heterogeneous world
and as we do that we'd be wise to listen
to all the different voices around us
thank you
[Applause]
Swamy changer Ganesha doctor channel get
some oxygen or get some protection
module a good whoa cheng'er Ganesha
hurry
Giorgio's before the hog lucre penis a
monocot want me to cook in the same
under God took a some procedure rz2
Chris um but be good to me they undergo
Oh Ganesha
marco piazza mermaid shutter now go make
it look easy
Ronnie Shirley not gonna kiss Turkey
Bobby no or not
I donated a army Swami - one day army
from but apart from the fish supper kiss
for me Oh Ganesha
Kumar dog is our guru Baba Gurdit us
Swami - my father Nakata me Mura
together call me Miss Ava customer Swami
ibaka Roberto judge or Ganesha Umaga go
try to suffer Quran of a beat swapmeet
suffered a fraud a puppy kiss of is a
mere Okayama yogi Savita me Lord I am
Kumar Kumar ta jaggedy Shehadeh Dean
Ivanka haha - mother trucker made a
Swami kumara rockabilly open a hog or
initially never daughter
I did only jagadisa hoodie they should
be guarded meow david swami got referred
or a beaver oh shut up
vagrancy go thunder Nick a favor
Oh deja can be sure honey
mana gonna suffer headed Swami supper
kuch na da la la la give me the won't a
jogger
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning graduates families and
friends my name is Alex Lee and a senior
graduating in Columbia College today
I'll be reading an excerpt from the
Christian Bible in the New Testament
account of Jesus's life there is a
moment when after Jesus arrives in the
holy city of Jerusalem Jesus the
supposed son of God and all of his power
and glory stands up from the meal he and
his disciples are having perhaps a towel
around his waist and washes his
disciples feet he then begins to speak
to his disciples about his death that is
to come saying this my children I will
be with you only a little longer you
will look for me and just as I told the
Jews so I tell you now or I am going you
cannot come
a new command I give you love one
another as I have loved you so you must
love one another by this everyone will
know that you are my disciples if you
love one another jesus's command for his
disciples as he thought about leaving
them was for them to love one another
what about us as we think about leaving
Colombia this beloved place of community
closeness and growth how about we face
the new environments rich with their new
people and new cultures that we are
about to enter into how will we be known
to the people will meet who don't yet
know us Jesus loved his disciples by
humbly act by the humble act of washing
their feet even when he was filled with
the power and glory as the Son of God
what if we love like that what if we
took the power we've worked so hard to
earn at Columbia and use it to serve
others I think that kind of love to
transform the worlds were about to enter
into and it is that kind of love that
makes those followers of Jesus thank you
[Applause]
good morning thank you to chaplain Davis
for inviting me to speak today and happy
Mother's Day to all the mothers
grandmothers and on here with us today I
am an Indo Persian American my father
was born in India my mother was born in
Iran my father is a Sikh my mother a
Baha'i growing up in a multicultural
interfaith household has shaped the
point of view with which I see the world
today marks the beginning of the 10th
year of incarceration for the seven
members of the Yaron the unofficial
leaders of the Baha'i community in Iran
there in present is just one facet of
the discrimination faced by behind
communities in Iran the High students in
Iran are not allowed to attend college
or university given that many lives in
Iran are denied higher education I feel
immensely privileged to have had the
opportunity to receive an incredible
education at Columbia and to be here
about to graduate speaking to you today
this gratitude and the values taught to
me by my parents from both their faiths
have shaped how I approach my years at
Columbia at the kernel of Sikhism my dad
taught me our three values carrots curl
do good honest work Bunch echo share
what you have with others and naam jumbo
say the praises of the Lord taking this
mindset to my studies at Columbia helped
to remind me that the value of my
education is not manifested in grades or
non exams or papers or the number of
classes taken but in the skills and
knowledge we've developed through hard
work and collaboration with others the
knowledge gained here extends beyond the
classroom to the activities of student
groups i opening conversations with so
different from ourselves in interface
spaces and interface intergroup
collaboration Mahalo the founder of the
Baha'i faith price knowledge is as wings
to man's life and a ladder for his
ascent its acquisition is incumbent upon
everyone the knowledge of such Sciences
however should be acquired as can profit
the peoples of the earth and not those
which begin with words and end with
words as we enter into the world endowed
with knowledge and awareness by our
Columbia education we must also be
prepared to share our love for the Arts
and Sciences in conjunction with our
beliefs and values for the betterment of
our respective communities and for all
communities congratulations for class of
2017 may we continue our pursuit of
knowledge share it with others and work
to use the privilege of our education
for the offense of all
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning happy Mother's Day
chaplain Davis rabbi hain Chris Coleman
Dean Valentini faculty mom dad and class
of 2017 thank you for granting me the
honor of sharing a few words with you
today throughout my four years in
college the Jewish community on campus
has been my home away from home my Haven
retreats the familiar and celebrate my
face but asked me when at Columbia I
felt my strongest sense of self I would
tell you that it was when leaving the
confines of my familiar in order to
embrace the other to quote the great
French Jewish philosopher Emmanuel
Levinas to approach the other in
conversation is to welcome his
expression it is to receive from the
other beyond the capacity of the eye
which means exactly to be taught the
relation with the other or conversation
is a non allergic relation in ethical
relation but in as much as it is welcome
this conversation is a teaching teaching
is not reducible to myotis it comes from
the exterior and brings me more than I
can contain in its nonviolent
transitivity the very Epiphany of the
face is produced Levinas further
developed this idea in his work nine
Talmudic readings in which he describes
how one can only exist in conjunction
with the other our identity only
emerging when it faces that which is
different like I'm sure many in this
room today would agree this idea is when
I find strikingly relevant to my four
years of study at Columbia my freshman
fall semester in literature humanities
was the first time that I sat in a
classroom with those of different
identities religions races and culture
I'd spent the previous 16 years of my
formal education learning the Bible and
its infamous tales but my Monday
Wednesday Lit home class was the first
time that I had the chance to explore
these stories through someone else's
lens I quickly learned that my religious
he made me a minority in the classroom
that semester I learned not to polarize
myself or my beliefs from those of
others but to listen to my classmates
his questions and develop my beliefs
with nuance and context it was while
volunteering in Ecuador with a group of
amazing Colombia women as the only Jew
the only non person of color and the
only Spanish speaker still grasping on
to her broken high school Spanish I felt
it while traveling with the chaplains
office as a craft global fellow to
explore the religions of India and
finally it has been through countless
conversations with friends roommates and
my fellow classmates about their own
faiths and ideologies these experiences
taught me that in order to form my true
identity I possess a need a need to
learn from and engage with others class
of 2017 thank you for giving me so many
opportunities to learn from you I hope
that each and every one of you has had
some similar experience here in which
you developed yourself and your beliefs
by learning from someone different from
you learning from difference is a skill
that will serve us well as we leave
these gates and embark on our journey
into quote the real world many of us
will leave here to start on our path as
future world leaders in the fields of
law medicine finance or social justice
wherever life after Columbia may lead
you I ask each and every one of you
today to embody Levy Knox's words and
view your relationships with others as
one of love and need not of hatred fear
or indifference use your Columbia
degrees to never stop questioning and
learning from others speak to those
whose customs may seem strange or even
offensive run towards others not from
them recognize your need for them and
embrace what they may teach you about
yourself thank you all and
congratulations class of 2017
[Applause]
my name is mo Cong I am different that's
okay
my family hails from Tamil Nadu India
growing up in an immigrant household
meant that English was never my first
language and that is where it all
started
going to preschool without knowing how
to say I wanted to use the bathroom in
English was a little jarring to be sure
but that was just the beginning
I grew up in st. Louis Missouri the city
which demographically was not the most
diverse city in America I spent the
first four years of school as one of the
only students of color in a
predominantly white Catholic school it
was here for the first time that I
started to question myself why did I
look so different from the other kids
why was my idea of God so different from
theirs as the odd kid out all you want
to do is fit in to be accepted to be a
part of your community instead at times
I felt myself having to explain why my
lunch to look different from everyone
else's or why I couldn't eat meat like
the rest of the guys fast forward a
couple years when in the fourth grade I
transferred to the LeDoux public school
district in st. Louis going to a public
school changed my whole outlook on life
seeing a variety of faces around me I'll
be no longer feel alone or afraid there
were others with me trying to figure out
where they fit both as Americans and as
second generation immigrants then
finally okay my senior year of high
school where I made the best decision of
my life to come to the best university
in the best city in the world Columbia
it was here that I got to the final
phase of my transformation
not just accepting the fact that I was
different but embracing it as a freshman
and East Coast first-timer coming to New
York was an overwhelming experience for
me
it was nothing like the cozy streets of
the suburban Midwest being tossed into
300-person engineering lectures in
poopin with a sea of students from Peru
to Queens only amplified that feeling I
was just looking for a community where I
could find and be myself and I found
just that with the Hindu students
organization here at Columbia as an
underclassman
on the club I learned so much from the
older guys and girls from how to sing
budgets and understand their meaning to
the best places to get quality Indian
food nearby learning from them both how
to dance and have fun at the volley and
Holi and also understand why we can do
celebrate each of these festivals truly
opened my eyes even attending lectures
on topics as seemingly far-fetched as
Hinduism and it's interesting parallels
to the movie The Matrix and volunteering
at thrift shops and food drives in the
Hindu spirit of community service peaked
a certain formerly dormant curiosity
about myself and my heritage as I grew
into my shoes I began to explore more
going on pilgrimages to temples in India
the United States and even Hong Kong
during my sophomore summer interning
abroad after three wonderful years on
the club I was given the opportunity to
be president and finally got my chance
to give back to the Columbia community
and help the next generation of
underclassmen with the recent uptick in
fina phobia and fear of immigrant
communities particularly the brown skin
kind I've helped organize multiple
interfaith events to promote tolerance
and compassion on campus and invited
friends of all backgrounds to my HSL
programming through it all I've come to
appreciate this campus so much more the
solidarity the love
and the understanding that I have
witnessed here has been truly inspiring
from protests on low steps to late night
conversations with my friends about
politics it's truly a beautiful place
after four years at Columbia I haven't
just accepted the fact that I'm
different I'm proud of it I am Who I am
and I'm no longer afraid to accept that
now coming this far wouldn't have been
possible without the love and support of
the immense number of people that I
would like to thank today first off to
my parents my little brother we're
sitting in the crowd today thank you
thanks for sticking with me through the
highs and lows and just encouraging me
to pursue what my heart told me to do in
life also a happy Mother's Day mom to my
friends and my support group from the
squad in st. Louis to my family from fam
here thanks for keeping a smile on my
face and keeping me sane these past four
years I'd also like to thank my
professors mentors and Dean boys here
that inspired me pushed me and kept the
flame of curiosity alive inside me also
quick shout out to the underappreciated
staff on this campus from the security
guards to the dining staff
we see you guys and we know that you
make this place run like a clockwork so
thank you and finally thanks to chaplain
Davis and her wonderful office for
giving me the opportunity to speak this
morning it's a great honor I'd like to
close with a message to the class of
2017 as we end our chapters here at
Columbia please always remember that
from this point on the real world around
us won't be the same as the wonderful
little bubble of this campus it will ask
us to conform it will ask us to adapt it
will ask us to forego our roots or even
tell us that we are not welcome here
but please don't let anyone else tell
you who you are or who you should be
that decision is yours and yours alone
you are different and that is okay thank
you
[Applause]
so I think the file clear while they
might take away China I I traveled every
Highway and more much more than hi
[Music]
each careful step along the byway and
more much more this
[Music]
Oh
ah
oh wow
I
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
Netaji drachma good morning yomijima le
mama cat hello Ella Bache Apache
may we be together as one on this
morning on the indigenous land of the
Lim a lanai people like the linen Linate
the Chickasaw people hold that land is
sacred to our identity we affirm this
knowledge through our oral history that
tells how centuries before Europeans
arrived on American soil two brothers
and chief neeko shotta and Minko chicks
ax led my ancestors from a hostile
territory in the land of the Setting Sun
to search for a more peaceful homeland
our only helmsman was a wooden pole
called et vibhava
holy tapa at the end of each day's
journey this sacred wooden pole was
planted in the earth and at daybreak the
direction that it leaned determined the
bearing that the people would travel
when the pole no longer leaned but stood
straight up and down the people would
know that they had arrived at their new
homeland the progress of such a great
caravan of people was slow but they
pressed onward in the direction that the
poll indicated always toward the Rising
Sun and when the people came to the
banks of a massive body of water that we
know today as the Mississippi River
Ettie a basa holy Papa leaned eastward
undeterred the people crossed the water
and persisted in their search until one
fateful morning when the sacred pole
began acting
Rangeley first it wobbled erratically
and then stood perfectly straight Minko
tatka was convinced that this was the
awaited sign of a new homeland but his
brother
Mingo Chickasaw disagreed insisting that
if a basa holy dopa was telling the
people to press onward Minko
Chickasaw picked up the sacred pole and
invited any who felt as he did to follow
the majority of people remained with
Minko Choctaw and ever since this group
of people is known as the Choctaw but a
small contingent my ancestors followed
Minko Chickasaw and today we are known
as the Chickasaw while the story
provides no indication for how long
Mingo Chickasaw and his followers
traveled my ancestors remained faithful
to the direction indicated by the sacred
pole even when the poles suddenly
reversed directions to take a westward
bearing heading straight back from where
they came eventually though and I
imagine to everyone's great relief it II
tsubasa holy tapa stood straight up and
down bringing my ancestors a mere 100
miles north from where they had earlier
parted company with their Choctaw
brethren in the early 1800s United
States government forced the Chickasaw
people to remove from our homelands in
Indian Territory a region that would
soon become the state of Oklahoma
despite this displacement from our
sovereign territory the hearts and
identity of my people will always remain
tied to that fertile landscape that
today composes the northern portion of
the state of Mississippi as much as the
religiously devout Chickasaw majority
find within our migration story an
affirmation of faith and divine
providence the story of atif abbas aho
Zacapa also resonates with those like
myself who lean toward scientific
evidence and that shows the burgess
shale within the burgess shale so
showing that human existence hinges upon
fortuitous randomness of nature but
whether one understands this Chickasaw
story as one of spiritual destiny or the
luck of the draw this oral history
asserts the inextricable link between
indigenous land and identity above all
my peoples origin story speaks to the
Unconquered and unconquerable spirit of
all Native American peoples and our will
to preserve our heritage and territorial
sovereignty the Chickasaw migration
story is a narrative choice and Trust
setbacks and endurance separation and
belonging and much like the long journey
that brought my ancestors to our
homeland
I took the circuitous route to
Columbia's school of general studies
from aspiring rockstar to meditation
teacher to wife and mother of three
daughters and public school volunteer I
arrived on campus unsure what I was
looking for other than a sense of the
longing I said about completing the core
curriculum along with a fairly random
selection of classes until some internal
divining pole pointed me toward the
anthropology department there I met
native and non-native professors and
colleagues who taught me how to look for
signs of my indigenous families erased
history the fortuitous payoff of my
academic gamble led to the reclamation
of my Chickasaw hair
teach language and identity and a
renewed sense of belonging Chickasaw
Governor Bill Anna to be States being
Chickasaw is who you are in your heart I
know that I feel at home there is a
yearning inside that gets filled it is a
part of you it makes you whole and
although my time at Columbia University
has brought me closer to that feeling of
home and belonging I must now set out to
find my place in the larger world after
graduation I will continue to remain
mindful of the signs along the way and I
imagine that there may even come a day
when like Mingo Chickasaw I will take a
stand on an issue and find myself having
to part company with a family member or
colleague however if I'm as fortunate as
my Chickasaw ancestors I will make my
way back to familiar territory
individuated separate and sovereign yet
close enough to my brethren or
colleagues to meet up around some
campfire coffee shop or casino game
table where we can count the stories of
our common ancestry as each of us
embarks upon our post-graduation
journeys whether we believe that our
next steps are guided by divine
providence or derived from the
serendipitous tilt of a wooden pole may
it e ba bossa holy tapa always lead us
closer to each other and that feeling of
belonging and home llamo Mizuki
good morning everyone
first and foremost I'd like to thank
Dean Hanson D screen and Dean Friedman
and chaplain Davis representing me with
the honor reflecting here today after
hearing so many wonderful reflections
and recitations it's an honor to be able
to share mine with this being one of the
first official commencement activities
to me it feels like the beginning of the
end everyone keeps saying it's not and
I'd like to believe that it's not but
there is change that awaits us as we say
goodbye to our respected faculty part
ways with our beloved friends and leave
behind our blankets of security and with
it all comes a sense of fear a sense of
the unknown a sense of fear for the
unknown a fear of the new and the fear
of all that leads ahead I'm not here to
say that it's not real or that we're
overreacting but what comforts me the
most is that we've done it at least once
before and considering the fact that
we're all here in our caps and gowns I
think we've done it pretty well four
years ago we all left home to come here
whether it was whether home meant a few
stops away on the one train that seems
to break down every other day or home
meant the world was no meant as far as
countries and oceans across the world
with fights that just seemed to get
delayed the closer we got to our
destination and I'm proud to say that
four years later we've made it when I
first received that Barnard admissions
packet saying majoring in unafraid that
excited me but over the years especially
over the past four that buried in
meaning as long as well as emotions with
it we made it through every paper that
we forgot about until the last minute
every exam that we didn't do so long
because the curve was not in our favor
unfortunately and every snow data ended
up not being a snow day because
facilities was so diligent and catching
the snow before the Grand cottage
amongst these nine through moments of
sadness fear of failure and perhaps even
tears in the Quran it says for indeed
with hardship will be ease indeed with
hardship will be ease it was in this
repetition that I found solace and
comfort through throughout out the
trials and challenges that I encountered
the fact that ease does not follow
hardship but rather accompanies it is
what gives me confidence that I've done
the best that I could and the hope that
the capability to do more exists because
with this comfort no task seems too
daunting and no fear no force seems too
mighty as we sit here today we're
surrounded by a sea of powder blue gowns
with the possession of familiarity and a
sense of belonging we may or may not
have passed each other in the hallways
sometimes pumped up on four cups of
coffee a lot of times after sleepless
nights a butler Lehman we mean or we may
not even recognize each other but at the
end of the day it was this institution
that United us all and as we part we
leave behind this home whether it's to
return to one that we came from four
years ago or one that we're building for
the next stage whether we meet again or
not our words will remain as well our
actions those that we performed and
those that remain throughout it all
Barnard College and Columbia University
has taught us all that it could immense
the in-class essays to take home papers
and the readings that I may or may not
have done yet there remains so much to
be learned however I truly believe that
despite all the peers and the number of
times my heart quavers at the thought of
paying taxes mortgages and paying bills
frankly adulting whatever that means
we were blessed with an education and an
experience that equips us to rise up to
the challenges that we encounter and
those that are wait us past these gates
because after all with hardship comes
ease once again thank you to Dean Hanson
Dean Friedman and chaplain Davis and our
esteemed faculty who have guided us
throughout all past
throughout the past four years and
hopefully for many more to come
an immense token of gratitude also goes
to my friends and family who have
decided to critique me endlessly but
love me relentlessly especially my
parents were nurturing me with the faith
and opportunities that makes me loud and
proud to be standing here today as a
Muslim as Barnard as Columbia and as a
New Yorker last but not least
congratulations to us the class of 2017
who has made it through more than we had
imagined but not all that awaits us but
there's nothing to fear because with
hardship comes ease with hardship comes
ease
[Applause]
let's give another round of applause to
all of our speakers and readers
to all of our musical groups another
round of applause I want to let you know
if this afternoon you're looking for
something wonderful to do on campus
Pease Mon is having its final concert at
two o'clock in the Earl Hall Auditorium
which is the building on the other side
of lo everybody's invited is that right
they are now I happen to be the
president of the fan club let us share a
moment of silence and Thanksgiving
may God be with each of us so be it as
seniors recess from the baccalaureate
ceremony student speakers your Dean's
and religious life advisors will be on
the chapel walk to greet you please
stand for the final hem Stan Columbia
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]